I don't like a lot of baked desserts.
I don't like cakes,
the cookies,
the cupcakes.
But I do love a really good pavlova,
and today I was craving one,
so that's exactly what I made.
I started by separating my egg whites from my yolks
and whipping those up
and slowly incorporating sugar into that mixture
until it got to the consistency I wanted.
I pulled out my whisk,
and I knew it was ready when I saw the stiff peaks form.
Then I put in some powdered sugar and some vanilla.
Once that was all incorporated,
I scoop my meringue onto my baking sheet
and create a little wells in the middle.
Then I let those bake for about an hour and a half
and let them cool for another hour in the oven.
In the meantime,
I made a little peach puree.
I just let my peaches boil on the stove
with some maple syrup and some lemon
and then blended it all up.
Combination of peach and passion fruit is so good.
So I added some passion fruit to my peach puree
and then moved on to making my whipped cream.
I was feeling girly today,
so I made it pink
and then decided to assemble my little pavlovas.
I washed and cut all of my berries,
and then it was time to assemble.
So I took my merengue,
spoon, the whipped cream into the wells we created,
topped it with the passion fruit
peach puree.
And all of the berries.
I also added some mint to it.
The consistency of these was divine.